the supporters of Bernie Sanders who in
this campaign got much farther than
everybody expected applaud him for his
moral vision and even newspapers like
the Washington Post and New York Times
who are not very supportive of the ideas
of Mr Sanders applaud him for presenting
a moral vision and those same people say
well this is what's lacking we filled
with into are a lot of plans but worst
efficient so that's my question to you
worst edition well let me say first I've
known Bernie Sanders since he was mayor
of Burlington we've been friendly we're
not best friends for a long time and in
fact during the campaign one British
newspaper found a letter that Bernie had
written to me in 1988 explaining why he
would never become a Democrat and how
corrupt the Democratic Party is so
obviously you know birdies changed his
mind over time and you're absolutely
right he's brought a surf morality but I
would say it's
not the most mature morality because
just talk about the way he talks about
banks and Wall Street it's one thing to
have a reformed position on how to deal
with banks it's another to say he does
terrific everybody who works on Wall
Street's immoral I mean that's
condemning lots and lots of regular
people who go to work every day in the
finance industry trying to make a living
or not head of Goldman Sachs who were
not taking home billions of dollars and
you need a finance industry in any
country to make a modern economy work
and contrast how Bernie talks about
these issues with Elizabeth Warren the
senator from Massachusetts she has the
same morality but she's a lot more
specific and she tells a narrative that
is less you're bad I'm good but more
this is the wrong way to organize things
there are better ways to do it and I
think what's going to be really
interesting about
and his people is does that energy
dissipate after the primary season ends
what's going to happen to Bernie's army
in fact I've been involved with some
discussions already about that question
because it's a very important question
and it goes beyond how moral little mrs.
Clinton is because when bill clinton was
president one of the things he said to
me he said all the pressure on him is
from the right wing there was very
little political pressure on Bill
Clinton when he was president he was
constantly fighting off a Republican
Party who said the day was elected he
was a legitimate large business
interests who fought every even smallest
perform to remember mrs. Fitton tried to
get national health care when he was
president all the big corporate
interests opposed her and they actually
prevented it so one of the questions we
have when Obama won and there was all
this energy Obama defeat of his Clinton
he brings out all these youthful
activism what's going to happen that
when he gets elected and some of us
suggested to the White House that he
made good use of names of the list and
set up an organization outside the White
House that would be a kind of political
force to his left to keep the pressure
on and they didn't do it they actually
refuse to do it they didn't want to have
that happen well now something more
interesting might happen because Bernie
will be in the Senate he won't have
disappeared if he chooses to make good
use of all those names and those small
millions of people have given him a
little bit of money he could become a
very effective pressure from the left to
make it easier for mrs. Clinton to do
progressive things and in this regard if
you're in Europe you should pay
attention to Senator Burke Elizabeth
Warren elizabeth is a very important
player in all of this because it's going
to be partly her role to keep Bernie
inside the tent and more important
because I don't think birdie is going to
do something silly and run third parties
not Ralph Nader but his supporters and
to have a voice they respect Elizabeth
Warren talking to them about how
important it is to not only support vote
for mrs. Clinton but just stay engaged
after so I think there could be a happy
kind of outcome for all of us that you
get a democratic party that's United
it's progressive and it makes it even
more important for what mrs. Clinton
proposes to get past if it's got support
from all the people supported hurting